sorry I was going to start this video
but I realized that I had um pepper
spray in my pocket no that's gonna
bother some of you and that's gonna
bother some of you and I don't know what
to do about that none of this seems
exactly right how do all the beauty
gurus do it I don't oh that's a blanket
that I in the washer like set literally
seven times because I would put it in
the washer every night and then forget
to put it in the dryer and so I just
kept washing it every day over again
because I thought it would get moldy and
its moldy so it's that's its little
holding data until I put it into a
garbage can I may miss go tell me if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now welcome to a video in
which I woke up this morning and I just
wanted to film a video I haven't had
that genuine urge in a second so I
thought I'd act on it before my anxiety
and insecurity kind of tackled that idea
to the ground and told me to no I went
on Twitter and I asked you guys for
questions we're doing a basic [ __ ] Q&A
video not their basic [ __ ] questions
it's just that Q&A videos are kind of
the iced coffee of YouTube videos you
know this doing Q&A videos is slightly
hard because I feel like I talked about
so much in my life on the podcast I do
with mamrie that's make it weird segue
we're doing a tour in the midst of being
on tour right now
[Applause]
well the links to tickets if you want to
come see us live or in the description
do any videos always feel like I'm kind
of talking about things that I might
have already talked about on the podcast
which is candid and fun and wild and
free and zany and silly and he can't
unhear a lot of it took my family a long
time to figure out YouTube I'm so glad
that they haven't figured out podcasts
yet so let's get into your question
what's your best advice on how to not
screw up College just nail it no don't
get too hammered sock it to them aim for
that honorable wrench and let our tools
what our tools are our tools I'm one and
you write me a letter of recommendation
so I can get into law school okay to
whom it may concern J crimes aka the
chubby nerd should be allowed to educate
themselves on law in order to defend
civilians
xoxo grace girl that'd work
do I need to drive six hours to
Minneapolis or are y'all going to do a
show in Chicago at some point this year
as of now all of the tour dates are
locked in and we do not have any other
future dates locked in yet but you guys
will be the first to know
oh god I'm having adult female puberty
right now that was the weirdest throat
sensation that's what she said me said
barely because something happened in my
throat oh it was like a ghost was down
my esophagus and then just squirm their
way up whoo you know if you had to date
a fast-food mascot which one would you
choose I would choose grimace I thought
about this for like 3 seconds and
grimace is the one I would choose
because I feel like we're both
introverts a little bit we surround
ourselves with more extroverted
characters and we'd understand like
giving each other space not wanting to
offend each other like we would just be
really emotionally distant and also
physically distant I don't know that
there's any way to romantically grimace
that'd be chill I would take grimace and
we live in two separate houses and
just masturbate separately what's the
most basic item of clothing you own so
I'm graduating college next spring what
do I do now
panic completely don't try to use your
education and apply it to real life in
order to move you forward in the
socio-economic world in which we all
have to try to thrive in truly just
regress and ask for help
don't take opportunities that present
themselves don't network don't find
communities of like-minded people stay
inside stay safe do not thrive are you
okay no no one's okay what's the
definition of okay what is the
definition of okay this is informal term
as an exclamation it means used to
express ascent agreement or acceptance
do you want to hear the next one no it's
used to express ascent if it's used to
express ascent then yeah I am okay
because I got a strong odor coming from
me today
whew that has reached shots on taking
time off from school yeah if that makes
sense for you school and education will
always be there I also think school is
one of those things that you have to be
in the right mindset to absorb it cuz
one it's super expensive it's okay in my
book to like take your time and figure
out when your brain sponge is ready to
absorb the education grime if you go
through school and like your sponge is
still that stiff unvoiced pre like just
straight out of the package thing just
spend a lot of money on what buying
plastic bottles vodka and getting drunk
with people that you've made mistakes
with that can happen at any age I went
to school I'm look at me now I got a
giraffe head and a moldy blanket on my
floor
why do I keep caring about someone who
doesn't care about me I've talked to
them and still nothing has changed what
do I do I feel like I have to put so
much effort into them it's pointless to
stop caring but I also don't want to
look stupid for giving up after doing so
much give the up and move on
okay clunky metaphor because we're great
at this think about the worst movie that
you've ever seen you walked away from
that movie being like that was terrible
look onto the next one that movie had
hundreds of people working on it how
much effort put into this thing but from
the outside looking in you were like
that's no good move on your relationship
too you might feel like you put tens of
hours of a day into it and it's the most
important thing in your world you think
the people that worked on the movie
hitch that put so much time and energy
into that film like have any good
customer interaction memories from your
days as a waitress I was the best most
unremarkable
waitress you could ever imagine I have
no truly great stories because I was so
amazingly happy and my interactions were
so mundane Oh blast
so not exciting that I have no way to
answer this question in a thrilling
remarkable way if you were on Shark Tank
what would you pitch to the Sharks
classic t-shirts with built-in armpit
absorption situations we'll call it
Under Armour perfect race do you have
any writing advice do it do you have a
feeling / motivation for getting off
your butt and doing something creative
and feeling particularly block recently
I've kind of realized because I was just
working on this like project with a
bunch of animals on set and animals that
are trained to be on sets are a very
particular type of animal with a very
particular handlers and you have to be
very particular about the way that you
interact with them because the slightest
thing can throw them off emotionally and
then they don't perform correctly so you
have to give the animal time and space
to go like reset itself and come back
and be okay and that's what my brain is
my brain is like a show dog or like a
show cat need to give it some space and
time to go reset itself and not force it
to just be on all the time I'm starting
high school next year do you have any
advice yes also just know that this is
impossible for you to understand but
just know that high school the four
years are not the most important years
of your life and if they are
yikes what is something that surprises
you no matter how often it happens when
I travel and I get to my flight on time
and I get to board the plane and I'm
sitting on the plane and then they take
off and I get to the destination that
was intended when I booked the ticket
I'm shocked what happens when someone
who is basic wears acid-washed jeans
hydrolysis please I don't know if that's
even the correct sort of pun here I
googled it Phil I googled it this is the
craziest thing about the internet I
asked for questions and I got two
amazing scientists astronauts just
respondus thinks this is so nuts okay
that's it for this video I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did give it a thumbs
up leave a comment down below and saying
any okay that's it for this video I hope
you guys enjoyed it uh if you did give
it a thumbs up leave a comment down
below and saying any of the questions
that I respond to on your own and don't
forget the memory and I are going on
tour we are currently on tour if you're
watching this video now so get your
tickets down below and I don't know
hydrolysis please you better hide
something you get a salt solution and
it's a just I lied mmm-hmm the
Internet's nuts